prior to 1906
when the pure food and drug act was
passed there were no regulations
regarding the ethical use of human
subjects in research
there were no consumer regulations no
food and drug administration
no common rule and no institutional
review board
a well-known chapter in the history of
research with human subjects
opened on december 9th 1946
when an american military tribunal
opened criminal proceedings against 23
leading german physicians and
administrators for their willing
participation in war crimes and crimes
against humanity
among the charges were the german
physicians conducted medical experiments
on thousands of concentration camp
prisoners without their consent
most of the subjects of these
experiments died or were permanently
crippled as a result
as a direct result of the trial the
nuremberg code was established in 1948
stating that the voluntary consent of
the human subject is absolutely
essential
making it clear that subjects should
give consent and that the benefits of
research must outweigh the risks
although it did not carry the force of
law the nuremberg code was the first
international document which advocated
voluntary participation and informed
consent
in the late 1950s thalidomide was
approved as a sedative in europe
it was not approved in the united states
by the fda
the drug was prescribed to control sleep
and nausea throughout pregnancy
but it was soon found that taking this
drug during pregnancy caused severe
deformities in the fetus
many patients did not know they were
taking a drug that was not approved for
use by the fda
nor did they give informed consent some
twelve thousand babies were born with
severe deformities due to thalidomide
us senate hearings followed and in 1962
the so-called kefauver amendments to the
food
drug and cosmetic act were passed into
law to ensure drug efficacy
and greater drug safety for the first
time
drug manufacturers were required to
prove to fda the effectiveness of their
products before marketing them
an equally well-known chapter in history
occurred during a research project
conducted by the u.s public health
service
600 low-income african-american males
400 of whom were infected with syphilis
were monitored for 40 years free medical
examinations were given however
subjects were not told about their
disease
even though a proven cure penicillin
became available in the 1950s
the study continued until 1972 with
participants being denied treatment
in some cases when subjects were
diagnosed as having syphilis by other
physicians
researchers intervened to prevent
treatment
many subjects died of syphilis during
the study
the study was stopped in 1973 by the u.s
department of health
education and welfare
1964 the world medical association
established recommendations guiding
medical doctors in biomedical research
involving human subjects the declaration
governs international research ethics
and defines rules for research combined
with clinical care and non-therapeutic
research
the declaration of helsinki was revised
in 1975
1983 1989 and 1996
and is the basis for good clinical
practices used today
issues addressed in the declaration of
helsinki include
research with humans should be based on
the results from laboratory
and animal experimentation research
protocols should be reviewed by an
independent
committee prior to initiation informed
consent from research participants
is necessary research should be
conducted by medically or scientifically
qualified
individuals and risks should not exceed
benefits
finally the belmont report was published
in 1979
with attempts to summarize the basic
ethical principles identified by the
commission in the course of its
deliberations
the report is a statement of the basic
ethical principles and guidelines that
should assist in resolving the ethical
problems that surround the conduct of
research with human subjects
the belmont report established three
basic ethical principles
respect for persons beneficence and
justice
which are the cornerstones for the
regulations involving human subjects